frontier defense mode Chris I did not
expect that livestream when I came in
this morning Erin does anybody like Ford
mode I remember you saying when respawn
was talking about horde mode you had a
bit of a sinking feeling and it's just
like feels like the thing they do cuz
they're like we want people to like play
our game a lot more and we what can we
you've got these mechanics in place
let's just throw a bunch of dudes in
there make them shoot a lot of them but
then we actually saw the Horde mode and
it actually looks really good yeah it
actually looks kind of cool so it's like
I don't know why so let's it's on a
bunch of different maps they take names
like four or five literally a couple in
the livestream let's do a quick
breakdown so frontier defense mode is
basically four player co-op yep players
are defending a harvester but it's like
a little tower though Tower plunk down
at some point in the maps you already
know but respawn has gone and taken a
ton of mechanics in this game and
changed them so now the AI wields all
weapons and they come in waves on the
rise map and ways of up to 200
grunts at a time well it's not just
grunts right it's grunts it's spectres
its Titans and they're also new variants
so like there are suicide specters that
are bright orange and running you if you
punch them explode so maybe don't punch
him there are new Titans that their job
is to just like run up and nuclear eject
in your face there are like cloaked
enemies that have drones hovering over
them there are sniper inspectors that
shoot you with like arc cannons from far
away so they like sort that's one of the
ways that enemy diversity is one of the
things that sort of spices it up because
like AI and titanfall is important but
it's also kind of a means to an end we
also suspect as rodeoing Titans which is
a brand new thing so it's cool on the
pilot side we also have a lot of new
tools or at least new new life being
breathed into old tools so we have the
turret which is brand new it looked like
something that's earned by Team score
yeah it's just one of these like turrets
you get as like a kill streak reward and
Call of Duty or you've seen it in other
games you just plunk it down wherever it
Auto fires on enemies you put it in
front of a lane of grunts
hopefully grants go away yeah what I'm
most intrigued with though is breathing
new life into some old stuff like so the
ice pick something that was never very
useful in in multiplayer that's like the
pilot ability that lets you hacked her
it's quicker or hack specters quicker
now I'm thinking hack giant packs of
spectres and put them to work for you
you know additionally the arc cannon
which I think people sort of late in
this game got the hang of mm-hmm I mean
what is the limit to the number of dudes
you can chain kill with an orangy zap in
one glass with that thing yeah cuz there
were a lot of burn cards and weapons
that it sort of felt like a little bit
like niche like you have to you're gonna
have to play a very specific play style
on a very certain map to make this
really work for you but now you've got
stuff like the slammer mod for the LMG
like it's super important to be able to
rodeo Titans and kill them quickly and
then hop off because there are tons of
enemy Titans coming at you there's not
just six like six enemy Titans on screen
as a max you would ever see in a
competitive match but in this
cooperative mode like 10 20 depending on
the map and the wave there's just a ton
and you really need to chew through them
quickly also a burn card like Wi-Fi
which is a complete throwaway burn card
for the entire time I wanna makes that's
the one that auto capture spectres
around you right so you know you pop
Wi-Fi you run into a giant group of
enemies specters and suddenly you've
collected a giant group like a Jenner
motto of spectres fighting for you and
makes you play in a different I mean
it's plain it makes you play in a
different way but it also like you said
takes these things and makes them really
annoying or useful in a different way
depending on who's using them the
example I'm thinking of is there are
mortar Titans which will just like perch
on the outside of the map like lob
mortars onto the harvester and they'll
straight up throw up one of those
shields so you can't snipe them from
afar you kind of gotta like go out of
your way to take them down because
they're just bombarding the harvester
the whole time and I think response done
a really good job of adding adding like
phases to the maps so if you have the
mortar Titans bombarding your harvester
that means you're suddenly gonna have to
split your efforts between you and other
players these players are gonna have to
out and defend locally and then other
players are gonna have to run across the
map and drop the mortar Titans are
you're gonna lose yeah so it's it's
really cool like during different waves
I think players are gonna have to switch
up their tactics they do have a weapons
crate so you can actually hot-swap your
your weapons and gear okay without like
III died now I changed my loadout you
can just go to the crate and go ahead
and do that
I guess the question then is so we're
feeling a little more I'm feeling a
little bit more interested in it than I
certainly thought I was when I heard it
was a horde mode but why is that like
why does this interest you
you know I we both enjoyed titanfall but
you don't play titanfall regularly now
do you I probably haven't for a while I
certainly haven't I mean one of the
things with titanfall was I felt like it
wasn't a game that could last forever
some people might disagree with me but I
got the the number of hours out of that
game that I wanted to get out of that
game I think it was a fantastic
experience now the cool thing about what
respawn is doing now is they're
basically keeping their cards close to
their chest and then making
announcements like this where they're
you know they're doing big updates or
they're doing in this case a big DLC
they're letting you sort of naturally
discover it on your own which intrigues
you and makes you want to go back into
the game and I think every time they do
one of these they do entice players to
come back for periods of time and and in
flight titanfall again yeah I think the
thing that entices me about it is that
kind of getting to use burn cards that
normally I just felt were too specific
to be useful in an attrition match or
capture-the-flag match I think it's also
taking on the AI in in a way that's more
significant than you did in the
competitive matches cuz yeah I was there
but it was not like something you really
had to contend with and strategize about
your most your strategies formulated
around what the other team is gonna be
doing a big thing they were talking
about during the livestream we watched
when they were playing at a bunch is how
they think this is going to be a way for
not just people like us who are like hey
something fresh in titanfall let me get
back into it I like that game a lot but
also people who are maybe new to
titanfall or maybe didn't play it that
much but who are like not the sharks out
there who are like ghent
and like just you know racking up triple
digit scores on attrition every match
that's intimidating to get into the way
they're sort of scaling the waves and
the way that they you know if you fail
away if you start that wave again you
know you don't go back to the beginning
you start with the Titan you start with
a sentry turret they're really trying to
make it so that it's a little more
welcoming which I like because I like I
really like the core mechanics of
titanfall and I think the more people
get to play that the more that that kind
of thing will just become that kind of
creativity will become valued in sort of
the shooter landscape yeah it's a way
for new players to level without
basically getting and highlighted by ten
50s and also like let's be honest any
time you get into a match and somebody
on your team doesn't even have their
first icon their precision or their gen
you're like oh boy this is gonna be a
rough match it's gonna be a doozy
there's a few other sort of details to
cover real quick I mean new achievements
on Xbox one it's coming out tomorrow
October 23rd for PC and Xbox one no word
on the 360 version the PC version is
gonna have new graphics options they've
done some optimization of load time
stuff
I think there's ranked matches as well
yeah they've also treated a couple of
the things they've made the black market
a little bit more useful so now there's
gonna be new voices that you can only
get in the black market and one of the
other cool things that we just read in
their patch notes was that the black
markets gonna have the ability for you
to buy and cheat your way out of certain
generation requirements so I really
don't like that grenade launcher on the
fight and we can work around or if you
really don't like me you know getting
those gooses where you have to shoot the
pilot and after they eject oh you might
be able to buy your way out of those
challenges which is a very black market
thing to do and by you mean you're not
meaning like buy some Xbox LIVE points
and spend or do you mean like buy with
other in-game sort of you're literally
using your endgame currency to buy your
way out of Galan generic that you don't
like there's also some other upcoming
modes that they've started talking about
that they're not gonna be out until a
little bit later one of them that
intrigued me was basically don't touch
the ground mode so I missed that part
okay so basically pilots are there's
going to be burning some
on the ground and pilots are gonna have
to play several modes I think including
capture the flag without actually
touching the ground of the map which
sounds like a lot of fun that it sounds
like the thing you do in your living
room with the couches and the chairs and
like clambering all over your stuff in
your house when you're a kid
the developers affectionately referred
to it as they don't touch the lava mode
floors lava
yeah nice so that's that's an upcoming
that's not and this update tomorrow
mm-hmm all right
so overall Chris do you think that this
mode is gonna bring players back in the
titanfall yeah I think it will I mean
I'll certainly fire it up and give it a
shot it'll be interesting to see how
they sort of you know message it other
than sort of like videos like this one
or you know videos like there's just
like how do people how do they let
people know like hey there's this new
thing over here maybe you're gonna enjoy
it and also communicate the fact that
like yeah Tord mode but like it's not
it's really kind of interesting I think
it's it's interesting because the way
that AI is already sort of woven into
the fabric of competitive titanfall you
know it's not like a Call of Duty where
there's no AI in the competitive mode
that's only in the single-player mode
and so the Horde mode there is sort of a
separate beast this just sort of feels
like a logical mutation of Titan Paul's
competitive mode which is cool so yeah
big surprise today frontier defense mode
coming out in titanfall tomorrow for PC
and Xbox one yeah looking forward to it
should be interesting